[Música]
Donald Trump fue el primer presidente en
ir dos veces a juicio político el primer
ex mandatario en enfrentar cargos
penales y ahora el primero en ser
hallado culpable de abuso sexual este
último caso pareció pasar por lo bajo
ante los medios de comunicación si se
compara con las páginas que ocuparon
temas como el escándalo con las con la
actriz porno milenials no conforme con
eso el ex mandatario se burló de las
acusaciones de su denunciante vamos a
hablar de ese tema y por ello saludamos
a Rafael peñalver el es analista
político y abogado en derecho
constitucional y bienes raíces de
Estados Unidos señor peñalver Bienvenido
a directo América
un gusto También es inevitable notar
como este caso en el que Donald Trump ha
fallado culpable de abuso sexual ha
tenido poco protagonismo sorprende
especialmente dada su posición de ex
presidente y de precandidato además a la
casa blanca porque cree que no ha sido
noticia en un mundo lleno de casos de
mitú
porque en un mundo
en el que vive Donald Trump que todos
los días hay algún escándalo ya la gente
está que uno más no cuenta tiene una
base que lo va a apoyar No importa lo
que haga una base dentro del partido
republicanos 30 35% no importa lo que se
le acuso no importa lo que sea con
Víctor ellos no van a seguir apoyando y
Donald Trump Pues todo el mundo sabe la
vida personal de Donald Trump nadie le
asombra nada y sabemos su actitud hacia
las instituciones Así que es uno más es
decir que estamos hablando tal vez de la
normalización del comportamiento de
Trump
así es Es una es una situación única en
la historia de este país donde una
persona que que hace un llamamiento
hacia la moralidad en su vida personal
pues es todo lo contrario y el pueblo
norteamericano ya son tantos los
escándalos y tantas las situaciones que
te repito uno más no cuesta ahora Trump
por ejemplo apareció el pasado miércoles
en un panel de CNN en el que no solo se
burló de Carroll su denunciante sino que
aseguró que fue un honor haber
propiciado la caída de Robert versus way
que protegía el derecho al aborto en el
país el mandatario está convirtiendo
este caso en una estrategia misógina tal
vez para ser política sí es una
estrategia de apelar aquellos
sentimientos del de dentro del país que
que apoyan este tipo de de posiciones
pero acuérdate que él fue convicto en
este caso principalmente por su propia
forma de actuar El desafío todas las
normas no compareció al juicio se burló
de los del juez acusó al juez de ser una
persona que estaba Imparcial y tienes un
Jurado de personas que han dejado sus
trabajos que llevan han estado dos
semanas oyendo evidencia la la
demandante presentó evidencia creíble y
el demandado Donald Trump ni siquiera
compareció al juicio su abogado fue
extremadamente antagonista y todo eso el
Jurado lo observa para mí Donald Trump
fue su peor enemigo en este juicio ahora
Trump dice que esto es una estafa dice
que ni siquiera sabe quién es ella usted
mismo lo mencionaba él ni siquiera se se
presentó a este juicio qué opina de esta
estrategia que anula a la víctima y que
le falta el respeto al propio caso
Le falló en lo que fue el caso porque
fue convicto pero en la estrategia de
Trump es una estrategia mucho más grande
es una estrategia de tratar de llegar a
la presidencia y esa esa Esa esa ruta
tiene el que tener el apoyo mayoritario
de en las primarias republicanas él está
contando de que esa base que él tiene de
un 30 a 35% no le va a fallar y mientras
más candidatos hayan en el partido
republicano para la presidencia en las
primarias Pues si él tiene un 35% sólido
el resto se va a dividir entre cinco o
seis candidatos y él va a seguir siendo
el el ganador del partido republicano ya
después en la lección general ya veremos
el como están las cosas hoy en día con
la economía norteamericana en una
posición incierta un presidente que
tiene 80 años sería una persona que la
la más vieja que jamás tomaría posesión
si es reelecto cualquier cosa pudiera
pasar en la elección general en este
momento la estrategia única de Donald
Trump es ganar la primaria republicana Y
ser el candidato del partido para la
elección presidencial antes de
centrarnos concretamente en esta
antesala a las elecciones de 2024 quiero
cerrar este tema de la atención
mediática que por ejemplo se volcó sobre
Trump y Carroll quedó casi que en un
segundo plano En ese sentido la actitud
desafiante de Trump desestima la
legitimidad del caso ante el público
cree usted totalmente
es insólito que el día después de haber
sido convicto salga en una en un
programa nacional y vuelva a insultar a
la persona que el día anterior le ganó
el caso y tiene un veredicto de cinco
millones de dólares ayer los
abogados dejaron anunció que están
preparando una segunda demanda por daños
y perjuicios de debido a lo que dijo
Donald Trump en revista el día siguiente
de haber sido encontrado
responsable de la de la del acoso sexual
Acuérdate que fue encontrado responsable
de acoso sexual No de rapto él cuando lo
acusaron originalmente de de haber
tenido una relación impropia pero la
relación impropia no fue de haber tenido
penetración etcétera simplemente de que
Había tocado indebidamente a esta señora
y por eso fue con Víctor Entonces él
sale él sale diciendo no me encontraron
culpable sí no lo encontraron culpable
de la legato de rapto lo encontraron
culpable de haber sido de de relaciones
impropias y de haber y de acoso sexual
precisamente al ser un caso civil en un
caso penal esto podría implicar para
muchos menos relevancia porque cree
usted sí porque el caso civil no te
lleva a cárcel Lo que pasa aquí que es
en este que este es un caso que fue hace
muchos años atrás hace 15 años ya la el
estatuto de limitaciones ha pasado para
presentar un caso un caso penal la
legislatura de Nueva York hace dos años
pasó una ley especial diciendo que en
Casos de acoso sexual y violación sexual
se podía presentar una acción civil no
importa el tiempo que hubiera pasado por
eso es que esta señora puede presentar
esta acción civil pero ya el tiempo ha
transcurrido muy tarde para que el
estado presente un caso penal en contra
de Trump y señor peñalver ya para
finalizar por ejemplo estamos hablando
de un caso una condena por
asalto sexual así sea un caso civil o un
caso penal independientemente de de de
de cuál sea este la naturalidad de este
caso que tanto castigarán los electores
o los propios republicanos a Donald
Trump en las urnas de Cara a estas
elecciones de 2024
esto fuera algo descalificante en
cualquier otra situación Donald Trump
tiene una situación especial de repito
él dijo una vez que podía matar a
alguien en la Quinta Avenida de Nueva
York y no le pasaría nada Esa es la
mente Ese es el estado de mente de este
señor y los que lo apoyan pero yo creo
que no yo creo que vienen tres
investigaciones que están a punto de
culminar la investigación sobre la
participación del Trump en el asalto al
Capitolio del seis de enero la
investigación sobre el uso indebido de
los documentos de seguridad nacional en
marolago y la investigación sobre si se
trató de influir indebidamente a los
oficiales del estado de Georgia esos son
tres casos verdaderamente serios que yo
creo que cuando si si es que llegan a
presentarse si es que llegan a
encauzarlo por algunos de esos casos yo
creo que vas a ver un deterioro en el
apoyo aún dentro de esa base republicana
y están basándose con esa Esperanza
están basándose otros candidatos
republicanos que están esperando que
caiga Trump para ellos Entonces surgir
adelante Trump cree que la estrategia de
él es ser el que gane la mayoría en las
primarias republicanas y si logra hacer
eso no importa lo que pase con los
encausamientos etcétera si él logra
tener ese 35% y el resto de los
candidatos se divide en el resto del
voto y cada uno tiene diez cinco quince
por ciento Trump seguirá siendo el líder
del partido republicano no importa lo
que haya hecho no importa las
consecuencias que a otras personas
serían territorios descalificantes pero
para Donald Trump es un día más en su
vida tan turbulenta en Rafael peñalver
analista político y abogado en derecho
constitucional y bienes raíces de
Estados Unidos Gracias por acompañarnos
en este análisis aquí en directo América
Muchas gracias Andrés un gusto Siempre
igualmente y ustedes televidentes
también gracias por sintonizarnos no se
desconecten en minutos regresamos con
más noticias en nuestro último bloque de
directo América
[Música]